after more than two decades people are
still analyzing every frame and
perceived undertone of the matrix
franchise and things have gotten bonkers
get ready to question your reality as we
look at the matrix theories that would
change everything as regular Internet
users know there's a happy contingent of
moviegoers in the world to take a great
deal of personal pride in being able to
poke holes in a film's plot using an
arsenal of boring complicated tools like
science and reality these are the folks
who refused to engage with the movie as
a piece of fiction and instead spend
their days picking it apart as though it
was a documentary and not a piece of
entertainment one of their favorite
targets is the Matrix franchises claim
that humans are being used to generate
bioelectric power for the machines the
nerd community was quick to point out
that this was a pretty inefficient way
to do things
since the person's body would by
necessity consume more power than it
could ever put out it's a little bit
like trying to run a battery charger on
the batteries it was charging but what
if we told you that all of that was a
lie you've been living in a dream world
knew this is the world as it exists
today what if humans actually do produce
the energy necessary to juice up a robot
army and the world's most malevolent
second life server it sounds crazy but
there's a solid explanation for why we
wouldn't know about it according to one
theory on reddit we're all living in the
matrix right this second and our robot
overlords have programmed the simulation
to make it seem like we generate less
power than we actually do the purpose
plausible deniability and an easy way to
throw us off the scent keeping us from
ever taking the all too real matrix
stories too seriously
according to a long-running fan theory
neo was never the one at all sound crazy
then think about the parameters that
Morpheus lays out for his cyberpunk
Messiah he says that the one was born
inside the matrix as the ability to
change the matrix is code and would
eventually destroy the system while that
might sound like neo at first glance
putting a little bit of thought into it
put some dents in the description neo
wasn't technically
warned in the matrix instead he was born
in a goo pot and then jacked in he can
do some wild stuff while he's on the
inside but we never really see him
change the matrix itself just the things
he can do when he's plugged up and as
far as destroying the matrix goes he's
definitely chipped in but can we really
say that he was 100% responsible for
shutting everything down
obviously the descriptions of the one
don't fit me like a glove not the way
they fit someone else Agent Smith
he's right born in the matrix check able
to change its code that's all the guy
does in movies two and three and even
before he gets reintegrated with the
source at the end of revolutions Smith
has caused more damage to the overall
program than a baby boomer opening every
email in their spam folder what if the
secret human city of Zion hidden from
the machines the real world in which it
exists and all of its dripping wet
dubstep dance parties were never real at
all what if they were just another layer
of the simulation that's the premise of
what's known as the matrix in a matrix
theory a line of thought that takes us
in a decidedly trippy direction maybe
even the people who supposedly know the
truth don't know the truth maybe the
matrix is a Russian doll of false
realities all built inside of one
another to ensure that nobody can ever
truly escape proponents of the theory
point to a couple of issues in the last
two movies of the franchise the first is
the apparent ease with which Smith
manages to possess the body of Bain in
the real world even with all of his new
power transcending the digital plane and
rewiring a human brain doesn't seem like
the sort of thing that a glorified
pop-up window virus should be able to do
the second piece of evidence and one
that's far more convincing comes from
the one himself at the end of reloaded
and again throughout revolutions neo
manages to control Sentinel robots
outside of the matrix which even with a
healthy extension of disbelief seems
like a weird new skill set to develop
also if it really was the real world
how did neo get back into the program
after passing out at the end of reloaded
from the moment he walked on screen with
his rich baritone and cool sunglasses
Morpheus joined that top tier of
fictional mentors who will exist forever
in the minds of audiences he's obi-wan
meets Master Splinter with a little bit
of mr. Miyagi thrown in for good measure
too bad he might have been the bad guy
all along this one gets complicated but
let's dig into the intricate theory
those posted online it all starts with
Morpheus ship the Nebuchadnezzar
historically Nebuchadnezzar was the king
of Babylon back
in Bible times and more importantly to
the theory the man responsible for the
enslavement of the people of the Kingdom
of Jerusalem also referred to as wait
for it
Zion what truth that you are a slave
Neil want to see how far the rabbit-hole
goes
then you should also know that Morpheus
is the name of the Greek god of dreams
the theory goes that one of two things
could be going on either Morpheus is a
human who was sucked in by the machines
just like cypher in the first movie or
we're back to the idea that the real
world is actually part of the matrix and
Morpheus is just another program his job
keeping people convinced that they've
made their escape feeding them
misinformation and essentially keeping
them asleep and dreaming creepy one of
the most popular complaints about the
third Matrix movie is that it lacked the
usual amount of explosions the first two
pictures in the series had their fingers
on the pulse of the audience's love of
watching stuff blow up part three on the
other hand was more focused on
thoughtful chats Christ's allegories and
rather than giving the core cast a big
final fight scene it mostly reserved its
big action sequences for CGI squids
fighting secondary characters that let's
be honest nobody really cared about
instead we learned about programs that
were really interested in getting their
kid into a good school so what was the
deal with a little girl who Neal runs
into in the train station anyway sure a
humanizing moment for the perceived
villains of the film is always welcomed
but it seems like a lot of time was
dedicated to sati and her family
according to one theory that's because
she was a lot more important than you
might have realized some folks are of
the opinion that sati isn't the
purposeless program that her dad makes
her out to be maybe they suggest she's a
potential upgrade to the Oracle first of
all it said that her mother was a
software engineer which would certainly
help but let's not forget what the witch
house keys loved best symbolism during
the Matrix Revolutions
we get to see sati helping the Oracle to
make cookies cute
only but it could also be an image of a
young program with a lot of importance
partaking in an act of creation with the
mother of the matrix one in the long
line of theories devoted to explaining
how neo gets his real-world superpowers
this puppy gets sinister according to
one fan theorist Neos meeting with the
architect in the Matrix Reloaded has
more significance than we're led to
believe everything that the architect
tells neo is true there have been six
versions of the matrix and neo has
appeared in every one eventually leading
to a complete system reboot what he
doesn't tell neo is that this time
around he's decided to use the once
penchant for choosing the door on the
right
to lure him into a trap the architect
has made a whole new program
specifically designed to convince neo
that everything is going according to
prophecy it's a matrix within the matrix
built only to make neo think that he's
an unbeatable Messiah with abilities
that extend into the real world the
theory also points out that from this
point forward there's a new Oracle and
that she speaks in a more condescending
and long-winded fashion than we've seen
before
leading the theorist to believe that
she's actually the architect in disguise
and if that's not too weird for you the
whole thing eventually spirals into an
argument that the John wick movies are
all part of Neos new dreamworld - maybe
that's why we never see dogs in the
matrix just that one weird cat and maybe
why Keanu Reeves doesn't seem to have
aged more than a couple months between
the matrix and John wick people keep
asking if you keep a sharp eye out and
really pay close attention it's possible
just maybe possible that you noticed how
the CGI in the Matrix Reloaded gets a
little funky the scene where this
phenomenon is most obvious has to be the
fight between neo and the army of agent
Smith's faces get rubbery clothes sort
of flap around like capes in a world war
two ERA superhero cartoon and even the
sound effects weird what most people
would brush off as an unfortunate
side-effect
to have overly ambitious special effects
before the art of computer animation had
time to properly ripen some matrix fans
have worked into an in-universe
explanation according to one theory the
reason that things get all Scorpion King
during the sequence is pretty
straightforward
the matrix itself is having rendering
issues the program was never designed to
handle thousands of clones of the same
character copying himself that many
times
nor was it designed to allow for Neos
ability to change the laws of physics
around himself put those two things
together and you have a situation that's
familiar to anyone who has ever tried to
run a PC game that was just a little too
intense for their set up the simulation
dropped the graphics quality just a
little bit so that it wouldn't have to
slow down the action in the years before
the events of The Matrix humanity went
to war with the machines a race of
self-aware robots after a series of
global atrocities mankind fell to the
supremacy of their mechanical overlords
and wound up plugged into generators
being used as batteries while living
meaningless simulated lives or maybe not
if one fan theory is to be believed
humanity actually managed to beat the
machines after they burned out the sky
in their final desperate act maybe once
the machines surrendered the humans now
living on a planet without any other
means of survival programmed their
former adversaries to believe that
they'd won the war and maybe just maybe
they continued to reprogram the robots
to keep humans alive and happy in a
simulated reality this one might be a
little less mind-blowing and a little
more of a fun coincidence but here it
goes maybe just maybe
Star Wars is just another level of the
matrix
no really just give us a second to
explain it all comes down to this one
scene in attack of the clones when
obi-wan Kenobi is approached by a dude
in the business of dealing death sticks
old Ben does some mind trickery and the
misguided youth goes on his merry way
but wait
eagle-eyed viewers might notice that the
death stick entrepreneur is played by
none other than Matt Doran the actor who
played Nebuchadnezzar crew member Mouse
in the first matrix movie he's the kid
who gets excited about how he'd
programmed the woman in the red dress
and Neos first training exercise who
distracted the one from all the
exposition he might also recognize the
woman in the red dress as Australian
actress Fionna Johnson who shows up in
the same scene from Attack of the Clones
as a bar patron sound a little too
flimsy
if so well there's nothing to see here
move along check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]